for me it really posed the question of
what happens when we change from
television as the primary mode of
communication to on-demand programming
and the Internet and so since that time
we've moved from what I'll show you is
sort of the more rosy picture of the
effect of the internet on democracy to a
more apocalyptic view of it and there
are three big questions I think that are
posed by the change in communication
technology for democracy the first is to
what extent does the marketplace of
ideas which has been a cornerstone of
our theory of the First Amendment and
free speech to what extent had the
theory of the marketplace of ideas that
the best test for truth really failed in
the Internet age it's not clear that the
marketplace of ideas was ever either so
free or the best test for truth but
certainly in the Internet age I think
we're finding that it's not but it's not
that more voices is lastly leading to
greater tests for truth the second is
does democracy require some basic
agreement on facts among the population
and some minimal trust in institutions
right which is not to say that the
Internet is responsible for all of that
right but it exacerbates both mistrust
and this lack of agreement on facts and
the final point is does a democracy
require some way of defining the
political conversation and community so
which limits it to people in the country
who are human okay as opposed to for an
intervention into an election foreign
speakers as well as BOTS okay I'll talk
a little bit about BOTS with no offense
to Otto here so as I said there was a
rosy picture of the effect of the
internet on democracy up until certainly
the 2016 election there was the sort of
repeated sort of fawning of praise
particularly on the Obama campaign's
digital campaign geniuses who were able
to crack the code of the internet to
both raise money and to campaign there
was this rise in small Duren of
fundraising so that the internet enabled
people like howard dean and even like
bernie sanders to raise all kinds of
small donor money as well there was this
evolution in micro targeting that again
was sort of an element of through the
TaylorMade messaging and mobilization
campaigns of Obama and and others and
the idea that with the end of television
ads we might move to a more sort of
small D democracy kind of environment in
which different types of candidates
could run that didn't have to have big
war chests because they could enable the
you know YouTube or Twitter or the like
could facilitate different types of
candidacies with didn't have that kind
of money now what's happened since the
2016 election is almost you know uniform
apocalyptic forecasts about about what
the the internet is doing to democracy
well what are those sort of realms well
it's the you know idea of course that
the internet is promoting fake news or
it's this rise in Twitter bots and the
like that allow as I was saying before
communication from machines
impersonating individuals or of course
our friends Vladimir who is you know
representative of the foreign hacking of
the US election and then as well dark
posts on the you know that the idea that
you don't even know when you're being
advertised to and and so the identity of
people is being and institutions and
foreign governments is being cloaked in
the anonymity of the Internet right so
we move from to the Liberation Theology
of the Internet to this apocalyptic
forecast
[Music]